foreign
New York is where Society puts itself on
display the leaders meet each other and
their children Court each other the Old
Guard think they can keep out the new
people with impunity but nothing stays
the same forever change came from the
American Revolution but it was difficult
to live through all the same
I intend to bring the great city of New
York the Opera House it deserves
members of The Academy are very
determined it should not succeed you'll
need to pick a team that's it head to
head and one will be the winner Mrs
Russell is even more of a fighter than I
had realized
is there any chance come back to 6
protagonists would welcome you back with
open arms I never dreamed that I might
still fall in love but I wonder what
Agnes will think cousin dershel he's
taken a real interest in Marion that I
don't just want a husband on data yes
Bridge he's even handsome what more
could a girl ask for recovering the
opening of a new school in Tuskegee you
have never been South that need to show
the world there I colored people making
something of their lives
things are worse than I thought your
workers would pay barely enough to put
food on the table why must I be the
villain in every story I have lifted
whole towns out of poverty you're making
a terrible mistake stop so selfish I
won't be put in a cage have you
forgotten that you live here at my
pleasure
I'm afraid we have a serious problem I
cover all your backs but who's covering
mine
and that's what this is
you seem to have won the first battle I
intend to win the war
[Music]
please